all right before we go to a break we
talked this week about glenn beck's
reactionary fear porn as we talked about
it on yesterday's show we also talked
this week about donald trump floating
the idea of the death penalty
uh for people who
he believes i guess committed crimes
related to
spying on his campaign which is not at
all what was uh um claimed by the durham
report and this has become its own sort
of echo chamber story um donald trump
appeared this week on the glenn beck
program and on that program again he
talked about you know
we we used to kill the people that did
the things that hillary's people are
accused of doing as far as he's
concerned let's take a look at just a
little bit of this
so the biggest scandal was when they
spied on my campaign they spied on my
career there's no real evidence of that
of course there is it's all over the
place leslie they spied on my campaign
and they get can i say something
you know this is 60 minutes
and we can't put on things we can't
verify put it on because it's bad for
buying we can't put on things we can't
verify leslie they spied on my campaign
well we can't very well i'm totally
no it's been just go down and get the
papers
they spied on my camp the papers he
flushed maybe and they got caught no and
then they went much further than that
and they got caught and you will see
that leslie and you know that but you
just don't want to know
as a matter of fact i don't know that
[Music]
okay so that was a that was from 60
minutes uh years ago and of course
leslie stahl was right there was no
evidence of what trump was claiming but
now glenn beck is going to pretend there
is
we just don't have the facts well leslie
now you do and president trump is here
to discuss perhaps why uh cbs and
everybody else is not talking about this
welcome to the pro they're not talking
about it because fox news and right-wing
media have created a false story
uh and there is nothing to talk about
that's the reality program president
donald trump
well thank you glenn great to be with
you
thank you so uh this is this is pretty
amazing um you were right when you said
this is worse than a watergate this is
far worse than watergate and it's not we
don't seem to have anybody in the
mainstream media that cares about it at
all
well in watergate they broke into an
apartment in watergate and they
took some things and
nothing good about it and it turned out
to be a disaster uh this is far bigger
they
broke into my campaign and all of that
but perhaps most importantly they uh
they broke into
the oval office they broke into the
white house at the highest levels
so illegal
and as you know being somebody that
knows history probably better than
almost anyone else
that would have been
a short time ago it would have been
considered treason
and i agree you know what treason is
punishable by
uh
and a longer time ago it would have been
punishable by death
when there it is again
we ran a tough country yeah and i'm
wondering
i wonder if it's a good run
i wonder if there's going to be any
punishment at all um with this i mean
hillary clinton uh okay so remember the
people trump is talking about
have not been accused
never mind charged with any crime and
trump is talking about the death penalty
what happened here is that right-wing
media and the trumpian wing of the
republican party exploded because of a
court filing from special counsel john
durham
what they are saying trump and others
is that the
uh there is definitive proof in the
filing that democrats
i guess directed by hillary clinton
illegally spied on trump in 2016 and in
2017.
the truth is the filing does not allege
espionage it says
a clinton-linked lawyer
clinton-linked lawyer and you have to
then actually prove whether there was
any active link between them at the time
it just associated with hillary clinton
historically
obtained
non-public data from the white house and
trump's servers now
if it happened
as described
and you can indicate that a crime was
committed
then the lawyer should be charged
if you believe that there is an actual
operational link to hillary clinton then
you should demonstrate it and if there's
criminal liability okay but so you you
see we're already three or four levels
removed here and um there is no actual
evidence from the durham report there's
almost first of all nothing new in the
durham report
it's not an indictment it doesn't allege
criminal conduct uh it basically is an
issue of conflict of interest and what
john durham is saying is we've
discovered here a potential conflict of
interest
there's this lawyer sussman he worked at
the law firm perkins coy perkins coy
represents the dnc hillary's a democrat
there's a potential conflict of interest
here that that's what this is
fundamentally about so far and i got a
couple of emails from people in the
audience saying david why haven't you
covered this fox news is all over it fox
news is making you think hillary's about
to get arrested and indicted and
imprisoned
she's not
and again trump is talking about the
death penalty for people who have not
even been accused of a crime we're
talking about conflict of interest at
this point in time so that's what it is
if you want to see the clip trump glenn
beck we'll have it on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door
ready to eat no cooking no cleaning
dishes saves you a lot of time you can
choose from over 50 hot and cold meal
options there's smoothies grain and
noodle bowls soups i'm a big soup guy
many of you know that i also really
liked the vegan meatballs with marinara
noodles delicious
both eye and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save 35 dollars when you go to
splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below